KRISHNA: Hi, Googlers
and YouTubers.
Google is delighted to welcome
Professor Prasad Kaipa and
Navi Radjou to Talks at Google
and the Google speaker series
here in Hyderabad.
For most of us in India,
I think jugaad
is a part of life.
I think a lot of us growing
up have done lots
of jugaads in life.
And when we need do, we
know how to do it.
Navi has taken this concept
global with his hugely
successful book called "Jugaad
Innovation: Think Frugal, Be
Flexible, Generate Breakthrough
Growth."
And he has helped the West
understand what we know
intuitively, which is bottoms
up approach to innovation.
Navi is a fellow at the Judge
Business School, University of
Cambridge, and a thought leader
and strategy consultant
to many Fortune 500 companies on
innovation and leadership.
I went to the Indian School
of Business a
couple of years ago.
And I had the good fortune to
attend a lecture Professor
Prasad Kaipa gave there.
And he spoke about bringing
Eastern wisdom perspectives to
business management
and leadership.
I remember walking out of that
talk inspired and thinking
that was about the time that
management theory, which was
generally dominated by Western
thought, needed an Eastern
perspective.
And Professor Kaipa coaches a
number of CEOs and top leaders
at Fortune 500 companies.
And he is also the creator of
the Centre for Innovation,
Leadership and Change at the
Indian School of Business.
He also takes practical
Vedanta classes in San
Francisco on Thursday evenings,
and I think that's
something, when I'm there, I'm
going to try and attend.
Together, they have co-authored
a new book, "From
Smart to Wise." And it is our
privilege today to hear from
them in person, their thoughts
and perspectives on
leadership.
Please give a warm Google
welcome to Professor Prasad
Kaipa and Navi Radjou.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PRASAD KAIPA: Thank
you very much.
It's a great pleasure
to be in Google.
I have been in Mountain View.
I have been in your Singapore.
And I have been in,
now, Hyderabad.
What seems to be common is,
number one, energy.
There is a certain vibrancy in
just the culture, environment.
There is a certain speed with
which you resonate.
And I think, third thing which I
also find is, there is a lot
of smiling faces, which
is uncommon.
I'm actually puzzled.
You know, are you laughing
with me, or are
you laughing at me?
I don't know yet.
But it is really great, on a
Friday afternoon, to help
people with a lot of smiles.
Two reasons.
One, as Krishna was mentioning,
the wisdom seems
to be an area where we have
a lot to say about.
In India, you know,
we are the source
of five major religions.
But at the same time, many times
our approach to managing
each other, managing oneself,
is more Western than even
Westerners deal with.
In some respects, it's like
we have a schism.
During the daytime, we operate
in a Western way.
But the moment the office hours
are over, the bhangra
and the dancing and the fun
starts, and the prayers and
the various other activities and
the rare festivals and the
work and the life and the fun
seamlessly integrate.
That one continuous integrity
that seems to be the source of
energy, source of rejuvenation,
source of fun,
is something that gives meaning,
that gives purpose,
and that evokes passion for
us to be innovative,
for us to be ingenuous.
How do we tap into that, what is
the source of that, is the
question which has been, really,
in my mind from the
time I quit Apple Computer.
I was in Apple in international
marketing for a
while in 1980s.
I was in Apple University.
I was the head of school of
technology and management in
Apple University.
And I was a research fellow
looking at future directions
in how people learn, how people
think, how people
create, how people relate,
how people lead.
So this was in 1988, 89.
With a friend and partner called
Bill Atkinson and more
of a guidance from Alan Kay, we
began to think about how do
we actually design tools that
augment human intelligence.
I found out, after actually
spending a large amount of
time investigating, inquiring,
and interviewing about 200
extraordinary people,
including many Nobel
laureates, brain researchers,
spiritual leaders,
psychologists, sports
personalities.
We came back, and we tried to
see whether we could create a
prologue or artificial
intelligence systems to
capture some of what makes
people energized, what makes
people creative, what
makes people learn.
None of them worked, because we
found out we can scale up
mechanically elements
of human ingenuity.
But what truly differentiates
each one from anybody else,
what truly differentiates our
own innovation, our own
approach to life, how we
contribute and how we
[INAUDIBLE]
become our own brands
is not easy to scale
it up in that way.
I'm sure you guys well
may prove me wrong.
That is what I think in
more ways than one.
From 20 years ago to now,
I see a lot of things I
thought-- these are not
algorithmic, or they are not
possible to be scaled up--
I think Google has done a
significant increase in it.
So at that time, we realized
there is something called
learning that leads to
innovation and learning that
leads to wisdom.
One will allow us to do
a lot of things in
the external world.
One will give us a sense of
peace, happiness, serenity and
equanimity to deal with
the external crisis.
These two are front of the
hand, back of the hand.
So when I quit Apple, I
thought I will do user
interface design.
That's where I thought I'll
get the consulting.
But instead, we started getting
opportunities to do
leadership development
and develop
adult education programs.
23 years later, when this book
came out, we realized what we
needed to document was some
good stories on how
extraordinary people perform.
And then, how smartness can
help us and hurt us.
What are the differences
in smartness?
Some people are great in
becoming domain experts,
functional smart people who like
to stay within their box
and go deep down as a hedgehog
and become somebody world
renowned in their field of
expertise but are unwilling to
take risks, but are unwilling
to look outside the box and
have entrepreneurial sense.
On the other side, there are
people who are willing to jump
from one to another to another,
connect the dots, and
go broadly, but always need help
in executing to go deep
beneath the functional
smart people.
So for anything to be
successful, we need some
people who are great in
execution, some people who are
great in business thinking,
if you want to call it.
Together, they can
bring success.
We've looked at it and said, why
do people keep on going on
one end of the spectrum?
We call it the blue end of the
spectrum, being the functional
smart, red end of the spectrum
being the business smart.
In between is the freedom,
is the place of wisdom.
And that is what we have
been investigating.
We interviewed people like Alan
Mulally of Ford, or Indra
Nooyi, or Sam Palmisano of IBM,
and John Mackey of Whole
Foods, in India, Narayana Murthy
of Infosys or Kiran
Mazumdar of Biocon.
And there are several people
in Tata Group.
So we began to look at,
essentially, the story between
the West and the East.
It is like it's a book written
combining the wisdom of India
and the wisdom of the United
States, a lot more.
So based on those interviews,
we came up with
a very simple framework.
If you put it as an acronym,
to make it
easy, we call it wisdom.
In this book, we talk about
those six elements which are
represented by each letter of
the acronym, working and
acting with authenticity
and appropriateness.
Looks like oxymoron, but we need
both of them to be wise--
intelligent and flexible
fortitude--
once you take on a project,
how long you stay with it,
when do you let go, when do you
hold on, when do you move
on, which requires certain
discernment.
Shifting the perspective
from what I want
to what others want--
because these days of social
network, these days of how we
are interconnected, Google+--
when you look at it, it is not
what you do it that makes a
difference but how many people
like what you do.
And they amplify it, multiply
it, and begin to do something
with some of these ideas.
How many ideas that are floating
around in the world
have originated in you that
other people kind of, what do
you call, created a viral.
That's important.
So can I shift the perspective
from self-centered to
other-centered before
decision logic?
Do we know what part of our
important decisions are made
by infusion, instinct, emotion,
or data, wherefore,
openness to change the roles.
Sometimes you are the boss.
And on another project,
sometimes
you are a team member.
In some place, you are
the person who
gives all the ideas.
In some other project,
you are the person
who needs to implement.
But if you get stuck with one
role, saying, because I have
been in this role, I always have
to be in that role, you
get left behind.
So the role clarity,
how do I play that?
And finally, what are the things
you want for short
term, medium term, long term,
and how do you become
productive by discovering your
own drivers of motivation.
These are six things which
we touched upon.
And if you were to look at the
book, first we recommend, go
check out a website where we
have a, what do you call--
NAVI RADJOU: The assessment.
PRASAD KAIPA: --the wise
leader questionnaire
assessment.
For these six wisdom acronyms,
each of them, we have created
some questions.
It takes less than
five minutes for
you to fill it out.
If you go to
fromsmarttowise.com, you can
actually go take the assessment,
see where the
baseline is, and get the
book and read one
chapter at a time.
Don't read the whole
book at one time.
Read one chapter.
See what you can take
and practice.
Discuss with other people.
Put it on Facebook what
you are doing.
And discuss what other people
are looking at.
In your own Google circles, what
are all the ways in which
other people are thinking
about it?
And then, once you feel like you
got it into your DNA, move
on to the other one.
So that is how we have
written the book.
So I have given you just
broadly the framework.
And I'll let Navi
say a few words.
And then, we can take some
questions on that.
NAVI RADJOU: Sure.
I mean, Prasad did a great job
in terms of outlining the
contours of this wisdom
framework.
But essentially, in a nutshell,
something to kind of
clarify, so wisdom for us
is the application of
intelligence to serve
a larger purpose.
So what we are saying is not
that you need to kind of dial
down your smartness, but find
the kind of right purpose
where you can apply it in a very
context-aware fashion.
The second kind of piece of
definition of wise leadership
is this balancing act between
action and reflection and
introspection.
So because what defines a lot
of smart leaders get carried
away by action.
And we're just talking to large
companies last 10 days.
One of the big question they ask
us was, look, we have to
meet shareholders' expectations,
quarterly
returns are still important.
So it's all about action,
action, action.
But we were just talking to a
large IT service company.
We were saying, look, you are
facing a lot of competition in
the marketplace right now, where
if you only focus on
action, which is how can we
reclaim our lost market share,
you lose an opportunity to step
back a bit and to reflect
and introspect, to figure out
what caused this downfall in
the first place, and how can
we regain our past glory by
reconnecting with our
authentic self?
And that is often seen as
luxury, because we are all
driven in real-time kind
of mode all the time.
So I just want to kind of say
that essentially a nice way to
remember wisdom is many of you
might be developers, you know
the language C++.
So think about wisdom being
S++, smartness plus, plus.
So it's not about relinquishing
your smartness
but applying your smartness in
a context-aware fashion.
That's the first plus,
recognizing that contexts keep
changing all the time.
And then, make sure that you
apply your smartness with the
right intent and right
motivation.
Rather than saying, oh, I'm
going to show off how smart I
am, it's more about how can I
use my smartness to serve a
larger purpose.
So in a nutshell, that's what
it is, smart-plus-plus.
PRASAD KAIPA: Yeah.
So for example, you can
ask a question, right?
When you come into the room,
into any team meeting, will
people be excited?
Or when you leave the team
meeting, would people to be
more excited?
Think about that.
Because that's a sign.
Without you opening your mouth,
their opening their
mouth, they can actually tell
you about your contribution.
Similarly, you need to look at
it and say, when I have a
noble purpose to take care of
my people, your productivity
can be much higher.
Actually, there is a research
that shows, in a IT industry,
the productivity of a person
who is passionate, engaged,
and clear is 13 times more
productive than another
average employee.
This is 1,300% increase between
an average employee
and an extraordinary employee
who is passionate, finds
meaning and energy.
So think about it.
Let's look at how we can
take it forward.
And please, we are open to
questions and comments.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is [INAUDIBLE], When you
talk about, say, business
thinking or strategic thinking
versus domain-specific
specialties, I think a lot of
times, it's your natural
inclination to go towards
one or the other.
I believe it's difficult to pick
up the other side of the
spectrum, so how do you
recommend we do it?
PRASAD KAIPA: The best way I
recommend you do it is, first,
recognizing there
are limitations
to my way of thinking.
If we do not recognize that
there is value in the other
side and there is a way in which
they can complement our
way of thinking, first of all,
whatever we do becomes very
superficial.
It may be appropriate, but it
will never be authentic.
So first step is to acknowledge
the weakness.
That is the hardest part
several times for smart
people, isn't it?
First, we need to be willing
to learn from that.
Second step would be to
recognize that even if they
say something, it won't
necessarily make very much
sense to us.
If you ask them to explain it
in a way you can understand,
you can act upon, you will
both be frustrated.
So what is most appropriate to
move from one end of the
spectrum to other end of the
spectrum is to take what are
some steps-- they may give five
set recommendations--
pick one that is easy.
And pick one that you are
comfortable with, the low
hanging fruit we talk
about right now.
You take that step.
And then, move to
the next step.
And essentially, have
them as some kind of
a mentor or a coach.
Tell them, I'm going to take the
risk, but you need to help
me to be successful.
So other person's job is not to
criticize and find faults
with you but encourage,
appreciate, and help
you along the path.
If we can create a relationship
with people who
are on the other side of the
spectrum-- by the way, as you
can see, this works very well
even with relationships.
This is not just about a
workplace situation--
whatever we are talking about
as wisdom is also, like, for
example, to take it practically,
what Navi brings,
what I bring, are extremely
complementary.
He was a vice president
of Forrester
Research, a great analyst.
He knows how to write things.
I mean, his reports are world
famous on innovation in India
in some of them.
And I am a guy, what you call,
I pass gas through my mouth
most of the time.
That is what I call teaching.
So in some respects, if I have
to write, it becomes a major
problem, because I think
a big vision.
I try to look at the big
picture, and then I try to
articulate.
But the moment we started
working together, he started
asking me structured
questions.
But for me those are
the hardest thing.
It's like being straitjacketed.
You know, as a professor, I like
to pontificate and talk
big things.
But he said, but how
do you do that?
He said, can you tell me in
three sentences what you are
talking about?
NAVI RADJOU: Forrester
training, right?
PRASAD KAIPA: Forrester
training.
NAVI RADJOU: You can say
anything in three bullets.
PRASAD KAIPA: Three bullets.
NAVI RADJOU: You cannot explain
in three bullets.
PRASAD KAIPA: Yeah
NAVI RADJOU: Even the
biggest idea.
PRASAD KAIPA: Right.
NAVI RADJOU: Yeah,
right, right.
PRASAD KAIPA: So in the process
of it, we began to
write first blogs.
It was interesting.
We were able to really crank
out some very good blogs.
And they started showing
up in the top five.
So we know that the may to do
that is, greatness from two
partners, when they
are created as 1
plus 1 making it 11.
I couldn't do what we
could do together.
He couldn't do what we
So we began to do small steps.
Once we became comfortable, we
started writing this book.
I mean, the process,
of course, we went
through ups and downs.
And there were times we were
ready to break up.
It was like marriage
pretty much.
NAVI RADJOU: Please.
PRASAD KAIPA: But in that
process, we realized, as long
as we have a larger purpose, and
we have respect for each
other, I'm willing to learn.
Even after three years of
working with him, I have so
much to learn.
Even in this 10-day book tour,
I'm actually recognizing
several elements of him I had
not recognized in my three
years of partnership.
When that rekindles, when you
come with a certain feeling
that you don't know so much
about the other person--
you might put them in a box--
but you are willing to learn,
what is the new thing that is
shining, and you are willing to
appreciate that, that's a
partnership for much cleaner,
much more what you call a
value-creating point
of partnership.
That's what you need to do
to be a wise leader.
To move from one end
to the other end,
begin with small steps.
Trust the other person.
Let the other person
guide you.
Put a time to create
value that is
meaningful for both of you.
And recognize there will
be a lot of failures.
But be resilient.
I think, as you can see, these
are steps for successful
personal relationships as well
as team relationships.
That's how we apply what
we are talking about.
NAVI RADJOU: The only thing I
would add is that there is a
way you can do that is, Intel,
to give a very concrete
example, allowed their IT
executives, they are sent on a
rotation program.
They have to go live and breathe
with the business side
of the house.
So the idea is that you begin to
shift your perspective from
the I-shaped person.
You became a T-shaped person.
So there are ways, actually,
where you can actually create
the empathy.
And at Walmart, they say you
have to think like a retailer.
That's a mandate of
IT executives.
So the empathy you
create one way.
But you get exposed
to the end users.
So I think there are ways you
can actually artificially,
using tools, to shift and
broaden the perspective
especially of the functional
leaders.
AUDIENCE: So I was reading
about this thing called a
philosopher king, where a king
would never be a philosopher
and vice versa.
And I've noticed that issues
with leadership and issues
with generally smart people
often start with something
called the ego.
I just want to know, have you
all addressed that in the
book, where, you know, learning
happens only when you
drop all your ego and
you are insecure.
And the more you learn, the
more insecure you get.
And that's kind of a
cyclical process.
So I want to know if you
all have kind of
addressed this thing.
Sadly, I was recently reading
about how, generally, most
leaders are also the most
narcissistic people you will
find in the world.
So I wanted to know if you all
have addressed these things in
the book and, like, kind
of called it out.
NAVI RADJOU: Yeah.
First of all, it's important to
clarify that, you're right,
most smart peoples are
self-centered and often selfish.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
NAVI RADJOU: It's very important
to recognize that we
are not recommending in the book
that you go from being a
very self-centered, selfish
person to a selfless person.
In that case, you have to become
a swami or monk, right?
That's fine.
But we introduce a middle
path, a middle ground.
We call it enlightened
self-interest.
That means, to use an American
English expression, that the
rising tide will
lift all boats.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NAVI RADJOU: And the reason that
a lot of smart leaders,
we think, are self-centered is
because their view of the
marketplace or the environment
is very much based on a
zero-sum game mindset,
that is, that the pie
is of a fixed size.
So unless I get a piece of it as
big as I can, I'm going to
leave it to the company
direct.
The wise leaders, they go
into a co-creation mode.
In other words, they say, look,
I have the confidence to
bring in the whole ecosystem
to actually
co-create this pie.
So the bigger I can make the
pie, and have the power to
make it, then everybody
gets a bigger slice.
So in a nutshell, that's what
we mean, enlightened
self-interest.
So for example, case in point,
Paul Polman, the CEO of
Unilever, has set a goal to
double the company's revenues
by 2020 while reducing
environmental impact by 50%.
It's about doing
more with less.
Now, is he doing it
out of altruism?
He, himself, on record,
won't say no.
This is enlightened
self-interest.
Because if I save on natural
resources, I save on cost.
And these cost savings I can
pass on to the customer.
And then, the shareholders
are happy, right?
So thinking in a more holistic
fashion, in a more systemic
fashion, that is also the
hallmark of wise leaders,
versus the smart leaders.
They have a very fragmented
view of the boat.
For them, it's like, doubling
revenues, I can
crack the code on it.
Oh, saving the environment,
let's ask the CSR
department do that.
But bringing them together,
bridging them and integrating
that, that's really, in a way,
what is wise leadership about.
PRASAD KAIPA: So to build on
that, as individuals, as
managers, we do three things--
what are we going to do,
is one question.
And then, how are we going to
get it done is the second
question-- but rarely ask the
question, why are we doing it?
We get into the minutiae of what
and how, but we lose why.
That's when exactly the
ego becomes an issue.
Like for example, take
Shahrukh Khan.
In one movie, he may
be a beggar.
In another movie, he
may be a killer.
In another movie, he may
be a romantic hero.
It doesn't matter what it is.
You can sit down and see
him and say, wow,
he lived this role.
But, you know, he is laughing
all the way to the bank, no
matter what role he plays.
He's in the character.
We are the one, if we like to
spend five times we go to the
movie, and making him
richer and richer.
Why is that important?
He knows, behind the actor's
role that he plays, that he is
Shahrukh Khan.
There is a clarity.
But he engages with the role,
fully knowing at the end of
the movie, he goes back to
being Shahrukh Khan.
That means the work that you
do does not change the
personality behind that.
If you have that role clarity,
then any project you take on,
you don't become
obsessed by it.
You may have passion for it.
You may have commitment
for it.
But if somebody comes in and
say, change the role, if that
is the best you can do.
We have seen entrepreneurs where
they start the company
in Silicon Valley.
You know, one guy took it
from $0 to $70 million.
And then, climate person said
we need to bring in an
external CEO, because, now we
are having multiple products
and multiple customers, we need
different experience.
Discuss it.
No, I won't step down.
I've built it from $0
to $70 million.
What makes you think
I can't take it
from $70 to $100 million.
But look at your own Google
Larry Page and Brin.
So if you look at it,
they started it.
They brought somebody in, let
the other person run.
You become an understudy.
And when you think it is
right time, you come
back and take it.
That is called having role
clarity about when do you need
to become a learner and when
do you become, what do you
call, a person who
is a teacher.
If you have that clarity, then
you see, even then you go
home, you will not necessarily
have the Google personality.
Google will become part
of your personality.
It is important.
Otherwise, many young people,
like Eugenics and Gen Y, when
you have a clarity about what
you are contributing, where
you are contributing, and what
is expected of you in terms of
your contribution, you will
not get burnt out.
You will have a longer passion
and a clearer set of goals.
And also, your innovation
will be at the sharpest.
I think that is where, I think,
the ego gets clarified
without the emotion getting
too entangled with it.
Think about it even in personal
relationships.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You made an interesting comment,
saying that sometimes
you think we are more Western
than the Westerners, right?
So when it comes to corporate
psyche, what do you think is
the elementary difference
between the way Westerners
think and the way Easterners
think?
And also, why is it that you
think we don't leverage enough
as Easterners from our culture,
from our values,
because we are just dealing with
the onslaught of a lot of
Western culture?
So it would be good to see some
inputs from you on that.
NAVI RADJOU: Sure.
In my first book on jugaad
innovation, I tackled that
topic, that essentially anybody
who would rise in
Indian streets know that if you
follow the rules and drive
in a very structured fashion,
you are going to die, right?
So this is a culture where
essentially everything is
unstructured.
We operate on Indian Standard
Time, which is very different
than, I know, the GMT.
We all know that.
So the question is--
this comes literally, we were
discussing about it.
It's very important observation,
because it comes
back to one of the critical
attributes of wise
leadership--
how do you try to be authentic
and appropriate?
You have to be authentic as
the Indians working in a
Western company.
So there are certain procedures,
rules, that they
have to follow.
That's what makes
you appropriate.
But what happens is the
same way with wisdom.
And that's why these two
books go hand in hand.
Because ingenuity is jugaad.
And wisdom is also something
that we hear about when you go
to temples on the weekends or
we hear it in our families,
talk about it in the evenings.
But somehow both, what we
discovered, is that when
people show up at 8 o'clock, 9
o'clock at work, throughout
the day, we forget about it.
But rather, we try to
be appropriate.
We are going to follow the
corporate procedures and
rules, et cetera.
But if there is a way to
integrate both, that would be
very powerful.
And case in point is
Renault-Nissan,
the French car maker.
They are now coming to India
to learn about jugaad.
Because they realize that they
have used what they call
frugal innovation, which is they
came up with the $5,000
car in France, in Europe.
Now, they say, we have
to create a car
which is 50% cheaper.
But you cannot do that unless
you change your way you think.
I love Europe.
So literally, in Chennai, they
are opening a frugal
engineering center out of where
they're going to create
the next generation
low-cost vehicles.
And the reason they are opening
it in Chennai is
because out of India they think
that this unstructured
way of thinking leads to
disruptive innovation.
The most structured you are,
you can come up with the
incremental innovation.
So if they try to do a
disruptive innovation in a
European context, what they will
come up with may not be
disruptive.
So I think one of the thing we
are hoping is that this book
and my first book is basically
an attempt for Indians to take
pride in what sometime
we take for granted.
Or maybe, practice it in a very
kind of subconscious way.
But it's so kind of fragmented,
right, because we
do that in our private lives,
but we don't do that in our
professional lives.
So that's what my kind
of part of answer is.
PRASAD KAIPA: I'll give it
from a personal side.
I have been living in the United
States for 32 years.
There was a time in Apple when
I had to give a presentation
for John Sculley in Japan in
artificial intelligence
conference.
Because I was representing
John Sculley, they went
through and they asked me to
go to Regis McKenna's group
and spend a lot of time both
for accent reduction and to
represent an American
company in Japan.
And I need to be able to
represent the brand.
So we went through several
days of accent reduction.
They said, you know, when
I say think, I need
to say it like this.
But I haven't figured it out
how much I should stick my
tongue out in sort of
my making myself
clear to other people.
Or they said, when you
use some words, you
need to slow down.
Indians speak so fast.
NAVI RADJOU: Machine gun.
PRASAD KAIPA: Like a machine
gun approach.
And especially when you talk
about our organization and
some of these words that have
got a completely different
meaning if you are
not careful.
So in that process, after
spending time with them, I
gave a talk, which was like
my almost ready for talk.
At that time, Regis
McKenna sat down.
He came back.
And he put his hand around me
and said, if you don't mind,
please unlearn everything
what we taught you.
We want you to go back to
your Indian accent.
I said, why?
They said, when you speak
with Indian accent,
your eyes light up.
There is intensity.
And there is gesticulation.
And there is you are present.
When you spoke the way in which
you are supposed to
speak, you represented
the brand.
But the value of the brand you
represent is so bland we don't
care about it.
I'm suggesting to us, in the
name of becoming Western,
sometimes it is like
a yin and a yang.
You need to see what
is your being.
Of course, you may ask, what
is this word, being?
Being is like Prasad has a
certain way of being oneself.
There is a way of expressing
oneself.
If I want to make a lighter way
in of it, Prasad keeps on
Prasad-ing.
Wherever I go, it doesn't matter
whether interaction is
10 minutes or 20 minutes.
Who I am comes through
when I am authentic.
Another way of saying being
is being authentic.
And the other thing is the
doing, which is the
performance.
If I am actually depriving my
Indian-ness, depriving my
Western-ness, depriving my
Japanese-ness, and if I try to
fit in, if I try to be
appropriate, whether with my
clothes, whether it is with my
accent, whether it is with my
interests, then what makes me
unique and contribute to the
job will be completely killed.
So my ingenuity, if I take on
what my colleagues work is, it
is translating creativity
into innovation,
depends on your ingenuity.
Indian ingenuity is
called jugaad.
There is a Chinese ingenuity,
Brazilian
ingenuity, American ingenuity.
Some of them are represented by
Apple and Google and some
of that stuff.
We need to know what
is that essence.
Keep the essence.
Drop the rest.
Then, you have an ability to
integrate East and West
extraordinarily uniquely.
And while you are building the
brand of your company, you are
not losing the authenticity
of who you are.
The wise leadership is about
being yourself while doing
what needs to get done.
When you do that, you are
not really enhancing
your personal brand.
You are actually enhancing
the corporate brand.
Because the diversity
will give you
different sets of ideas.
And that ingenuity translates
into coming up with Indian
products that may have worldwide
application because
you brought your Indian
thinking into
Western problem solving.
I think that is where
we can be wise
without losing our smartness.
And I hope that's what you
can take away from this
conversation.